right imagine nirvana in 1992 had social
media and on tick tock says our first
album's coming out and all the fans that
have been following us on tick tock you
can buy an nfp that represents a
percentage of the back end in perpetuity
now okay isn't that profound now i'm
getting goosebumps now you know this
fans hate when their band or artist gets
famous because they sold out and they
can't go see them when there's only 50
people in it now fans are going to make
their wealth from their favorite brands
making it interesting isn't that
fascinating
could one do the same thing for actors
you could do it for everything or i'll
give you a great one i argue that if nft
was mature in 1975 that george lucas
would be the richest person on earth
because every single collectible in
digital form giving george lucas a
percentage of not only the primary but
the secondary trend are you kidding me
yeah i mean look at ebay right now and
see how many tickets from concerts and
sporting events are sold a year stubs
every ticket's gonna be an nft within a
half a decade